règlement de comptes à ok carole laure
la québec aime son mec mais elle chante
les autres arts carole laure bonsoir et
la québécoise tic
des looks bon les français et d'apporter
la plus belle d'abord n'ont plus
vraiment la québécoise alors elles ont
pas non plus que les française des
télécoms
et ce en moins nombreuses c'est d'être
l'avenue sont beaucoup moins nombreuses
les gens quoi de moins qu'à 16 ans - les
québécoises
elles sont obligées alors disputé sans
obliger de faire des trucs vachement
bien côté de l'amérique
c'est ça alors aujourd'hui je sais pas
tu as l'air d'amorcer une reprise en
main de ta carrière je me trompe
ma carrière j'ose dire ma carrière ça mc
ça va toujours pas par vagues peut pas
être sans arrêt en grande à pepsi la
même façon la même égalité donc là je
suis boulimique des projets j'ai envie
faire
il ya eu deux trois années j'ai fait des
enfants là je veux faire des trucs qui
me passionne parce que oui au cinéma
depuis sauf toi lola t'as pas fait grand
chose vaut bien mieux après
moi mais bien ne pas les gêner mais je
les aime pas tous également quand je dis
que tu reprends ta carrière en main
c'est valable aussi au niveau du disque
bien sûr que des personnes est venue me
dire ce qu'il en est dans le train de
tester c'est moi tu es sétif et envie de
faire purement vous avez un goût de
charger bout de champ et les verts la
scène j'étais très amusant il fait un
peu comme liza minnelli en ce moment il
fait ça aussi
elle est allée voir les pet shop boys
elle revient je chante la toute toute
différente
toi aussi moi j'ai toujours chanté
puisque j'ai chanté dans les films dans
peu de temps mais j'ai pas refaire un
album solo conseil général assez bien
c'est vraiment
parlez à quoi que ce soit d'autre qu'un
disque
trahie quand même un peu la langue
française parce qu'il ya quoi il ya très
peu qui en français sur le site adapté
deux descendeurs la vérité c'est de la
transformer et une chanson de richard
cocciante sont elles donc lui aussi
adore faire des albums country
moi je suis très lucide sur les
adaptations si c'est parfaitement fait
d'accord mais certaines sont tellement
connu stand by humans j'ai pas envie de
faire
au québec ils vont pas gueuler que nous
chantons
castioni de faire le lancement québec
personne heures si je fais des projets
de chansons originales
évidemment je ne ferai pas anglais mais
quand c'est tellement connu celui du
matériel américain extrêmement connue
par salarié a dit j'ai bien droites
faire je peux chanter des chansons de
brahms en eux je chantais déjà fait un
tour en ville n'y a pas le nom non sans
concept sit-in mais comme vous été
dernier à parler français si même toi tu
te met à chanter en anglais si tu veux
pour nous c'est dur moi j'étais très
affiches francophones j'ai toujours j'ai
pas le complexe la francophone
j'ai envie de faire un projet est dans
une plage et bien droit d'en faire une
raison alors il ya ça d'abord touchante
beaucoup en anglais et puis lewis bon il
est producteur il est à ranger enfin sur
le disque a quand même qu'un kit de lui
et finalement nous ça complètement
refait les argents et la fin des temps
oui puisque mon honneur mon concept
était de faire de faire complètement des
standards des connus
j'ai pas plus d'infos matériel animer
des banques aux la nuit il fait des
trucs qui me fait des trucs à bout et
les écrits pour moi peut-être sera le
prochain album
il est pas en colère ça va pas du tout
ça lui est beaucoup plus je vois c'est
pas une séparation même disons
professionnels sur les wii la wii qui
étaient prêtes on va faire une interview
à peine dawn en anglais toi c'est prête
à peine d'arnaud kate
et ça
je finis de toi que tu préfères
tout ce que j'aime raconte dans ce
tableau ce réseau mais j'aime le premier
est évidemment la mort d'un bûcheron
j'ai découvert le métier en même temps
j'aime le prog parmi les premiers films
français que je fais j'aime préparez vos
mouchoirs de bbm ou journalier le film
de toi que tu détestes merci
il y en a je n'aime pas tout et moving
ou deux par les problèmes que la
manipulation tout ce que tu veux
je n'aime pas à noter que j'ai fait au
canada trapel dernièrement que ça fait
de ma nuit avec hortense
non viendront ensuite le monde l'a vu
c'est mauvais mais dix fois on aime on
aime ou on n'aime pas les signes pour
d'autres exemples femme humaine la plus
grande joie de bien-être où la troupe de
recevoir la découverte d'un métier
l'amour
voir l'amour
désir de l'amour dans l'air d'avoir des
enfants et oui la plus grande déception
président
ne pas avoir été noués avec les miens
par exemple
vtt recueilli quand l'été voilà comment
pas une déception c'est un malade qui
s'appelait comment ton village il ya un
enfant shawinigan l'endroit où la
rivière coule c'est ça c'est cette rue
peel totalisé un deuxième système était
bien un signe des temps c'est bien ce
que tu aimes le plus chez lewis furey
son talent son effet le jeune charles
ça fait beaucoup déjà là est ce que tu
aimes le moins chez nous
e
il passera autant j'aime traoré je suis
bazarder beaucoup plus et beaucoup plus
réaffirmé que moi qu'est ce que tu
penses avoir de plus sexy
ouf
dans sa salle
si je ne sais pas moi je pense pas qu'on
a ou le père de jean
ceci ou cela
ce que je pense et un ensemble
quand je pense que jeune ensemble de
défendre plutôt qu'une arme de qualité
mais c'est peut-être bien agencé
ce quota de moins sexy
c'est parti je sais pas ce que j'écris
je faisais moi
demandez à projan qui
à des messes en meneur derrière ses deux
enfants de x men
moi je ne passe au dessus
l'état garde par exemple ça fait un bout
ça fait cher qu'en france allez voir je
vais par rapport au 7 mai mais grand
défaut ce serait pas mal
c'est vrai je suis fatigué qu'est ce que
tu préfères le sexe
on va voir des livres référence ça
marche ça marche on accepte
tu préfères quel moment
quel moment je préfère d'un certain
petit moment je préfère j'aime
les chaufferettes diversifiée à défendre
mon état d'âme savary
j'aimerais pas la monotonie en sexe
l'inventivité temps j'ai eu alors parce
que j'ai tendance à dire qu'est ce que
tu me dis qu'est-ce que tu détestes
orsec ce qui fait que je dis un truc
vraiment ça que dégoût
même pas en entendre parler on a bien
bossé
qu'est ce que j'aime femmes - avi
on sonnait comme ça dans la vie
quotidienne poussette j'aimerais pas
l'habitude de l'indifférence pour compte
qu'est ce que tu préfères en toi
mais je me trouverai fatigante mais
oui oui
est-ce que tu détestes en toi pour finir
on ne répétera pas
ce que je déteste un mois
peut-être les membres de générosité on a
craqué sur les pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu